so I'd like you to join me on a field
trip and I want to go to the beach take
you all of the beach and so enjoy the
sea air and the salt spray and let's go
down to the water's edge and what you're
gonna notice is that we're getting
knocked around by the waves and it's
really difficult to stay in place right
but now look down and what you're gonna
see is that the rocks are covered by all
sorts of sea creatures that are just
staying there in place no problem and it
turns out that if you want to survive in
this really demanding environment your
your very existence is dependent upon
your ability to make glue actually so
let me introduce you to some of the
heroes of our story you're just just a
few of them so these are mussels and
what you'll notice is that they're
covering the rocks and what they've done
is they've made adhesives and they're
sticking down on the rocks and they're
also sticking to each other actually and
so they're there hunker down together as
a group this is a close-up photograph of
an oyster reef and oysters they're
amazing what they do is they cement to
each other they build these huge
extensive reef systems they can be
kilometers long they can be meters deep
and arguably they're the most dominant
influence on how healthy any coastal
marine ecosystem is going to be because
what they do is they're filtering the
water constantly they're holding sand
and dirt in place they actually other
species live inside of these reefs and
then if you think about what happens
when a storm comes in if the storm surge
first has to hit miles of these reefs
the coast kinda is gonna be protected so
they're they're really quite influential
and then if you've been to any rocky
beach pretty much anywhere in the world
you're probably familiar with what
barnacles look like and so what these
animals do and there's many others these
are just three of them what these
animals do is they make adhesives they
stick to each other they stick to the
rocks and they build communities and by
doing this and there's a lot of survival
advantages they get so one of them is
that just any individual is subjected to
less of the the turbulence and all the
the damaging features that can happen
from from that environment and so
they're all hunkered down there but also
that there's a say he's in safety and
numbers thing because it also helps you
keep away the Predators because they say
a seagull wants to pick you up and eat
you it's more difficult for this Fiegel
if they're all stuck together and then
another thing too is it also helps with
reproductive efficiency right so you can
imagine that when mr. and mrs. Barnacle
decide okay it's time to have little
baby barnacles I won't tell you how they
do that just yeah but when they decide
it's time to do that it's a lot easier
and their reproductive efficiency is
higher if they're all living close
together right so we want to understand
how they do this how do they stick and I
can't really tell you all the details
because there's something we're still
trying to figure out but let me give you
a little flavor of some of the things
that we're trying to do so this is a
picture of one of the aquarium systems
we have in our lab and everything in the
image is part of the system and so what
we do is we keep the in you can see in
the glass tank there in the bottom
there's a bunch of muscles we have the
water chilled we have the lights cycled
we actually have turbulence in the
system because the animals make more
adhesives for us when the water is
turbulent so that we we induced them to
make the adhesive we collect it we study
it as far they're they're here in
Indiana as far as they know they're in
Maine in February and they seem to be
pretty happy as far as we can tell and
then we also work with oysters and
there's a top it's a photo of a small
reef in South Carolina and what we what
we're most interested in is seeing how
they attach to each other how they
connect and so what you can see in the
bottom image is two hoisters that are
cementing to each other and we want to
know what's in between and so a lot of
times we'll cut them and look down and
in the next series of images we have
here you can see on the bottom will have
two shells with the shell of one animal
then the shell of another animal the
cements in between and if you look at
the image on the right what you can
maybe see is that there's structure in
the shell of each animal but then the
cement actually looks different and so
we're using all sorts of kind of fancy
biology and chemistry tools to
understand what's going on in there and
what we're finding is the structures are
different and the chemistry is actually
different and it's it's quite
interesting uh and then this picture I
guess let me let me step back before I
tell you what this is so I if you do you
know the cartoon the Magic School Bus or
if you're a little bit older Fantastic
Voyage right and you remember they had
these characters they would shrink down
to these microscopic levels and then
they would sort of swirl in and swim
around and fly around all these
biological structures I think of this as
like that except for it's it's it's real
in this case and so what we did is we
have to hoist earth that are stuck
together and this area used to be
completely filled in with the cement and
what we're finding is that the cement
has lots of different components in
there but broadly speaking they're hard
non-sticky parts and there are soft
sticky parts and what we did is we
removed the non sticky part selectively
to see what's left for what's actually
attaching the animals and what we got is
this and we can see that there's
actually this sticky adhesive that's
holding them together and I just think
it's a really cool image because you can
imagine yourself flying in and going
back there right so anyways those are
some of the things we're doing to
understand how marine biology is making
this materials and from a fundamental
perspective it's it's really exciting to
learn but what do we want to do with
this information right well there's a
lot of technological applications if we
can harness what the animals are doing
so let me give you one example here so
imagine you're at home and you break
your favorite figurine or a mug or
something like that right you want to
put it back together so where do you go
so you go to my favorite place in town
which is the glue aisle of the hardware
store all right I know you're where you
spend your nights but because you're all
hip cool people because you're here and
you're going to bars and concerts and
stuff like that this is where I hang out
so every night so anyways so what I want
you to do is get one of every adhesive
that's on the shelf bring it home but
before you put try to put things back
together I want you to try to do it in a
bucket of water it's not gonna work
right we all know this so obviously
marine biology to solve this so what we
need to do is figure out ways to be able
to copy this ourselves and one of the
issues here is you can't just go and get
the materials from the beach right
because if you go get a whole bunch of
mussels you try to milk them for their
tea so you'll get a little bit of
material but you're never gonna have
enough to actually do anything with
you'll get just enough to see we need to
scale this up ideally maybe train-car
scale right so on the top is an image of
one of the types of molecules that the
animals are using to make their glue and
what they are is they're very long
molecules are called proteins and these
proteins happen to have some fairly
unique parts in them that bring about
the adhesive properties what we want to
do is take those little parts of that
chemistry and we want to put it into
other long molecules that we can get but
things that we can make on a really
large scale and so you might know them
as plastics or polymers and so we're
we're sort of simplifying what they do
but then putting that adhesion chemistry
into into these large molecules and
we've developed many different adhesive
systems and doing this and when you do
you make annuities so that looks pretty
good what do you do you start running
around the lab just sticking stuff
together in this case we had just took a
tiny bit of glue and glued together two
pieces of metal and you want to hang
something from it to see it see what it
looked like and so we used a pot alive
muscles and we thought were very clever
we're obviously much more quantitative
about this most often and so we
benchmark against commercial adhesives
and we actually have some some materials
now that are stronger than superglue so
to me that's really cool right that's a
good day in the lab it's stronger than
the superglue right and here's something
else that we can do so this is a tank of
seawater and then in that syringe is one
of our adhesive formulations and what
we're doing is we're dispensing it
completely underwater on a piece of
metal and then we want to make an
adhesive bond or joint right so we take
another piece of metal let me put it on
there and just position it and you want
to let it set up for a while give it a
chance so we'll just put a weight on it
nothing fancy this is a tool with lead
shot in it nothing fancy and then you
let it sit for a while so it's never
seen air it's completely underwater and
you pick it up I never know what's gonna
happen I was very anxious here
pick it up and it's stuck to me this is
really cool so we can actually get very
strong underwater adhesion possibly is
the strongest or at least one of the
strongest underwater adhesives that's
ever been seen it's even stronger than
the materials that the animals produce
so so it's for us it's pretty exciting
it's it's pretty cool so what do we want
to do with these things well here are
some products that you're probably
really familiar with right so think
about your cell phone your lab top
plywood in most structures the interior
of your car shoes phone books things
like this they're all held together with
adhesives and there's two main problems
with the adhesives that are using these
materials the first one is that they're
toxic right so the worst offender here
is plywood plywood or a lot of furniture
or wood laminate and floors the main
component of the adhesives here is
formaldehyde and it's maybe a compound
you've heard of it's a gas and it's also
a carcinogen and so we're constructing a
lot of structures from these adhesives
and we're also breathing a lot of this
carcinogen it's not not good obviously
right the other issue is that these
adhesives are all permanent right and so
what do you do with your shoes or your
car or even your laptop at the end of
life when you're done using it for the
most part they end up in landfills and
there's a lot of precious materials in
there we'd love to be able to get out
and recycle them we can't do it so
easily because they're all stuck
together permanently right so here's one
approach we're taking to try and solve
some of these problems and what we're
what we've done here is we've taken
another long molecule that we can
actually get from corn and then into
that molecule we've put some of the
adhesion chemistry from the muscle so
because we got the corn and we've got
the muscles we call this our
surf-and-turf polymer and it sticks it
sticks really well it's very strong it's
also bio-based that's nice but maybe
more importantly here it's also
degradable and we can degrade it under
very mild conditions just of water and
so what we can do is we can set things
up and we can bond them strongly when we
want but then we can also take them
apart when we want something we're
thinking about and here is a place where
a lot of us want to be watching this in
this specific case is a place where we
do not want it be but we'd like to
replace this right so sutures staples
screws this is how we put you back
together if you've had some surgery or
an injury right it's just awful hurts
it's in the case of the sutures look at
how much you know you're making
concentrated mechanical stresses as you
pull things together you're making sites
for infection
poked holes and healthy tissue it's not
so good or if you need a plate on to
hold together your bones look at how
much healthy bone you have to drill out
just to hold the plate in place so that
is awful I mean it looks like these were
things devised in the medieval torture
chamber but it's our modern surgical
joinery so I'd love it if we get to a
place where we can replace systems like
this with adhesives right
it's not easy if we're working on this
but this is not easy so think about what
you would need for adhesive in these
cases right so first of all you need an
adhesive that's gonna set in a wet
environment right now if you look at the
silly little picture there it's just to
illustrate that our bodies are about
sixty percent water and sorts of wet
environments it's also to illustrate
that this is why I'm a scientist and not
an artist I did not miss my calling at
all so then and the other requirements
that you need for a good biomechanical
adhesive you also it needs to bond
strongly of course right and it needs to
not be toxic you don't want to hurt the
patients in getting any two of those
requirements and the materials pretty
easy it's been done many times but
getting all three hasn't been done it's
very hard and then if you start talking
to surgeons they get really picky like
so you know actually I want the I want
the adhesive to set on the same
timeframe as a surgery okay you know or
or all I want the adhesive to degrade so
the patient's tissues can remodel the
site okay so this is this is really hard
we're working on it this is just one
image that we have so what we're doing
is we're getting all sorts of bones and
skin and soft tissue and hard tissue and
sometimes well whack it with a hammer
usually we're cutting it in very precise
shapes and then we glue them back
together we've got some exciting results
we've got some strong materials some
things that look like they're not toxic
they set well it looks pretty good but
I'm not going to tell you that we've
solved the wet adhesion problem because
we haven't but it's certainly it's
certainly in our sights for the future
so so that's one place that we'd like to
think things go and farther down the
road and there are a lot of other places
too you can imagine we might be better
off if we could get more adhesives in
there so one thing is even cosmetics
right so if you think about people
putting on fake nails or eyelash
extensions here I'll do this
what do they use they use very toxic
adhesives right now so it's just right
for replacement that's something we'd
like to do and then there are other
places too so think about cars and
planes the lighter you can make them the
more fuel-efficient they're going to be
and so if we can get away from rivets
and good away from welding and put more
adhesives in there then we might be
better off with our your generation of
transportation so for us this all comes
back to the beach right so we look
around and we we wonder you know how do
these sea creatures stick and you know
what can we do with the technology and
and I would argue that we have really a
lot of things we can still learn from
biology and from nature and so what I'd
like to encourage you all to do in the
future is
put down your non recyclable laptops and
cell phones and go out and explore the
natural world and then start asking some
of your own questions thanks very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you